and so let's just say as an easy example
uh in the mount gox situation I think
people are getting back 25 cases tell
people about Mountain galaxies I just
heard about this when someone was coming
I haven't heard of that uh Mount Cox is
an exchange from back in like 2014 that
uh basically failed uh so similar
apparently Bitcoin back when it was like
600 [ __ ] crashed and it went to like
ten dollars a [ __ ] like a coin it was it
was the biggest exchange to what
everyone used yeah and uh they had a
bunch of Bitcoin in there and so they've
gone through a similar processes like
bankruptcy stuff and so what happened is
people basically got like an IOU
right which is like again it goes uh
counter to the Bitcoin ethos of like you
can do self-custody you can hold on to
the asset but because you had it in the
exchange you get an IOU and those like
we'll get back to you on how much you're
going to get so let's just say that you
had 10 Bitcoins sitting in there at 600
bucks or whatever it was uh now they're
giving back 25 so you'll get two and a
half Bitcoin now for those people you'd
rather have the 10 Bitcoin than the two
and a half but the price of Bitcoin has
gone up so much in dollar terms you're
like up but you'd rather have 10 Bitcoin
at you know 17 000 or whatever what
happens to those Bitcoin if there's only
21 million ever made and you there were
10. they can get spent they could like
that's where the question is where did
the two billion dollars let's say the
two billion dollars was missing from FTX
where did it go but even if you spend it
you have to give it to someone else to
spot it it doesn't disappear and it
never does someone who bought it
so you guys start you got this is what
this this guy is gonna have to try to
figure out where'd the money go
and are you confident they'll be able to
find it due to the confidence of
blockchain I think that uh the
blockchain will be peace uh some of it
but like just go through an easy example
so uh Andrew has an account on an
exchange that goes under uh they ended
up taking his money and uh they were
trading with it and he had a hundred
dollars on their worth of let's just say
um I don't know uh ftt and as they were
trading they lost money so now that they
only have twenty dollars of Andrew's
original 100 like technically they
didn't give it to anyone they were just
trading and they're bad Traders
so there's eighty dollars missing and
Andrew's like yo where's my hundred
dollars and then the bankruptcy people
show up and they're like yo there's only
20 left like here it is right right so
like you can't what are you going to go
do try to figure out like which one of
his ftt tokens who did you trade with
like they didn't it it's just different
than like if you took the money and you
went and you bought like a piece of real
estate or you donated it that's very
clear like who has it and then can you
get it back will they give it back like
that becomes part of the process gotcha
yeah I guess in that example I look at
ftt and I'm like oh that's like a proxy
coin that they're making but like with
Bitcoin are they they're not are they
actually using the actual coins so I
read something I don't know how accurate
this is uh but uh guess how many Bitcoin
they actually ended up having how many
zero what
supposedly and it isn't that convenient
it's very convenient but but it goes
back to The Narrative of life
like if you want to do this stuff
it wouldn't be at all connected with the
worst crypto scandal in history but this
is the whole thing right it's like if
you wanted to do all the [ __ ] yeah
remember I said yeah
all the [ __ ] goes on in this in the
rest of this thing and so like you don't
want to use Bitcoin if you're doing this
right and and why you can't control the
production of Bitcoin so like you can't
play Central Banker so like all right
that's less enticing and then what they
were doing is they were creating what a
lot of people in finance would call like
paper Bitcoin or wrapped Bitcoin is what
the crypto world would call it oh a coin
that's pegged to it they like try to
move it onto like a different blockchain
and now they have like an ethereum token
that represents Bitcoin but like how do
you know there's really a Bitcoin maybe
they could just create more of them so
it's paper bit like you get in this
world where like if you're the average
user you have no clue 99.9 of this is
going on
and so like again it's Finance it's the
same thing like when you put your dollar
in the bank like there's [ __ ] that they
do that when people hear about they're
like yo they could do that yeah like who
was the person who was like drunk one
night and figure that out yeah right
yeah that's what's going on in this
whole other side so I think like uh the
Bitcoin World in some ways the
bitcoiners are very like we told you so
like keep your coins off of exchanges
like all this stuff right which like I
would say uh some bitcoiners are very
hardcore like don't put your stuff on
exchanges there's other people right
more like me who is like look people are
going to maybe keep majority of it off
exchanges but they're still going to
want to use the stuff they're still
going to want to uh earn yield they're
still going to want to participate in
finance whether we like it or not
they're going to want to do it
um and so it's more about like the
responsibility don't put everything
somewhere right if you're gonna do it do
it with one three four five percent
don't do it with a hundred percent so I
think that that's the world that like
now people are starting to realize like
okay hold on a second Bitcoin is
different which is unfortunate we have
to go through this it's not the first
time it's happened but usually when it's
done happening is the net gain of
bitcoiners through this whole process is
like they're not messing with these
other tokens I saw a guy wrote a whole
thread he's like a hardcore bitcoiner
now and he was like yo back in the day I
got burnt but I didn't learn my lesson I
had to I had to touch the stove twice
interesting right and he was like by the
second time I got burnt I was like yo
I'm just into Bitcoin